welcome to serverless Expeditions Sarah
glad to be here Martin so a few months
ago you showed our team a really cool
way of Designing user interfaces as a
group I think your process could help
many viewers as they design their
applications happy to share
[Music]
so what was the problem you were trying
to solve I need a way to stay on top of
YouTube comments we have published over
a hundred episodes of serverless
expeditions and I would see when viewers
make new comments even on old videos so
I can respond to them have you tried to
build this before yeah we did a few
years ago we started building the back
end and how did that go well we got
stuck it's hard to design a backend when
you don't have a list of requirements
and then you told me about the designing
the user interface as a group and that
would sort of suss out the requirements
I remember asking you if you could wave
a magic wand what do you wish you would
have and you said that you wanted a way
to stay on top of YouTube comments and I
said that is your North Star and that
everything else should follow and that's
when I proposed a Double Diamond
technique it's something that I learned
from ux grad school and it was
popularized by the British design
Council and this is two-step process
first you need to figure out are you
solving the right problem and then you
can figure out are you solving it in the
right way so in other words you need to
figure out what you really need first
before you start implementing your code
for it I was excited about that because
it would help me get this project moving
again now what was the first step yeah
the first step was figuring out what
your real use cases were like what were
your actual tasks and what would the
minimum set of features required to
achieve those tasks right right you me
and the other team members discuss the
problem in the Discover over our face
and we had lots of Divergent ideas and
we then went into the explore Define
phase where we converged on our thoughts
and refined them into three use cases
and if I recall correctly a lot of the
features didn't really support that
North Star and I kept stressing go
minimalistic we can always add more on
later and then we enter the next phase
which is the design and test phase where
we iterate on different design
approaches and then of course we're
going to diverge again because no one
has opinions like ux opinions because
everyone is an expert in their own you
know experience so the thing with the ux
is how do you solve for that lowest
common denominator that Baseline set of
experiences right and you took us
through that mob user interface process
you've used that one before yep I
learned it at Silicon Valley co-camp and
it works very very well for projects
that don't have a dedicated ux engineer
so I also used it to teach a college
level course for this particular
software engineering course the students
had to build an app but it only had one
hour in the entire semester to teach UI
and ux techniques and so in that case
this technique worked extremely well
cool I actually didn't know you picked
it up from Silicon Valley code Camp all
right so we do lay out the process for
us sure so everyone draws for five
minutes they're a ux design and then you
spend about 10 minutes comparing designs
and everyone shares their ideas then you
do another round but this time you must
include one item from every other person
or at least one other person and then
you spend 10 minutes going around
showing what you came up with but also
you have to indicate I got this idea
from so and so and you repeat this about
another three times and what will happen
is you actually converge into a single
design yeah I remember when you set the
forums down in a conference room and we
did this exercise uh it was a lot of fun
uh we did three iterations right yep we
did three iterations and here are the
drawings from iteration one and you can
tell that they're quite different from
one another right we each had our own
ideas about how to implement the use
cases yeah and then here are the
drawings for iteration two you can kind
of start to see how they're converging
and you'd see this common theme
appearing a list of videos yep yep we
each took the best ideas we've seen from
the sketches made by others yeah and
here are the drawings from iteration
three where you see the UI is getting
more streamlined and more of a focus on
that list of videos and then we felt
that things were getting pretty similar
and this was a good time to stop and so
now the orange side of the Double
Diamond is done and we could have done a
traditional ux approach research
prototype and iterate nothing wrong with
taking the traditional approach but in
this case when we didn't have a
dedicated ux engineer right this
approach worked extremely well I agree
with that so that was the the end of the
workshop if I remember correctly and the
week after I took those sketches from
iteration 3 and I created a simple
mock-up in HTML yep we with the markup
as a
purpose and I remember we removed some
buttons and get the basic stuff working
first yeah I remember you kept pushing
Us Sarah you kept asking do we really
need that button yeah I'm a minimalist
and the idea is that you're going to
learn from the first version of the app
it's always more fun and rewarding to
add more functionality than it is to
take functionality away both from the
code base and from the users yes
so that was a fun and useful exercise
and we got the project restarted after a
year of no movement uh thanks for
showing us the way Sarah happy to have
helped the next step was to create a
technical architecture that will be the
next video but for now thank you
everyone for watching if you have any
questions for Sarah me please leave them
in comments we read them all especially
now that we have a good comment tool
also let us know if you have any
suggestions for serverless Topics in
future episodes
see you in the next video where we
designed the technical architecture
[Music]